all right let's give us some breaking  news now coming out of italy that  italy's prime minister mario draghi has  told parliament that he is going to  resign so let me just tell you that  again italy's prime minister mario  draghi uh has told the italian  parliament that he's going to resign uh  the house was just about to debate a  confidence vote in him and his  government and just to remind our  viewers that yesterday draghi uh won a  confidence vote in the senate but the  problem was  three of his crucial coalition partners  failed to vote in that and there was a  there was a general fear that without  those votes um his coalition his unity  government would resign uh so uh as  expected mario draghi has now told  parliament that he has resigned so more  on that of course as we get it here at  al jazeera